[Musique]
dormir entièrement allongée lors d'un
vol en classe économique ce sera bientôt
possible sur les ailes d'air new zealand
le transporteur méo zélandais prévoit
installer dans certains cas des avions
de petites capsules dortoir baptisé
skynet chacun des espaces va accueillir
six lits de deux mètres sur 50 cm avec
draps couvertures et oreillers les
passagers pourront réserver des plages
horaires pour se reposer pendant leur
vol et un uzi landau répond ici à la
principale critique des passagers en
classe économique qui attribuent leur
inconfort à l'impossibilité de
s'allonger
des critiques fréquentes parce que le
transporteur offrait les vols parmi les
plus longs du monde 18 heures pour
relier open à new york
[Musique]
s'il connaît du succès ce concept
pourrait même être vendus à d'autres
transporteurs
[Musique]